in the office of Falls editor we see
cover art for several misery books this
is the book series that made him famous
and caused his self-proclaimed
number-one fan to keep him prisoner
after he breaks his legs this one is a
French version of miseries love one of
the four misery books specifically
mentioned in the novel by Stephen King
miseries Quest is another and we can see
that cover right here the first misery
book is called The Adventures of misery
Chastain in the movie it's a little
easier to see later on in the film we
also get a look at the cover of the
original finale of the misery series
miseries child Annie would force Paul to
write a sequel to miseries child which
would be known as miseries return and in
the pages we see him writing there's
some Easter eggs you might have missed
stick around to the end of this video to
hear about them welcome to things you
missed today I'm covering the 1990 film
adaptation of Stephen King's novel
misery if you haven't figured that out
already that's what we're doing today
King was not really all that down to
sell the movie rights to misery at first
which I do find kind of ironic because
the main character kind of considers
himself a sellout
but according to Mental Floss he ended
up changing his mind because he liked
what director Rob Reiner did in adapting
his novella the body into the movie
known as Stand By Me which is a non
horror movie so I probably won't cover
it on my channel but there is one scene
that is truly horrifying anyway let's
get back to misery
[Music]
the movie opens with Paul finishing up
his next novel he's finally free of
making misery books after killing the
character in the previous one so he's
moved on to something more serious we
can see some of the text on the final
page of this book it reads I better not
take that for granted anymore he told
himself breathing might not seem like
much but without it what else was there
this is Paul not practicing what he
preaches not yet at least because at the
end of the movie he'll eventually admit
that he was taking his life for granted
before his experience with any will some
way will experience
help me Annie tries to make him burn his
book later on and in doing so we get a
glimpse of the first page but it
actually looks more like an essay about
teen movies and mentions say anything
risky business the graduate and Fast
Times at Ridgemont I after finishing
this new book Paul leaves the hotel he
was writing it at and his car has a vky
7 to 2 license plate which is a common
plate seen in a lot of movies like the
freshman shaft and the wolf of Wall
Street there are probably others I guess
this is like the Wilhelm scream of
license plates just before heading off
he throws a snowball at a tree which may
be a small nod to the fact that he
played high school baseball in the novel
where he supposedly couldn't hit a curve
and I wouldn't be emo Abraham Lincoln if
I didn't mention in this part earlier I
mentioned that we get to see the cover
of miseries child in the film and when
we see it you'll also notice that the
publisher is Viking press who in real
life at the time published several
Stephen King novels such as the dead
zone firestarter Cujo Christine The
Talisman the eyes of the Dragon it's and
of course misery
when Paul wakes up in Annie's house
after the crash she tells him where he
is we're just outside Silver Creek this
has changed from the fictional town of
Sidewinder Colorado in the book Silver
Creek is a real town in fact it was a
former mining town which could be a clue
about the old miners practice of
hobbling their workers a tactic that
Annie later uses on her prisoner there
are also references to mining in some of
the newspapers seen on screen usually in
things you missed whenever there are
newspapers there are Easter eggs mainly
consisting of the art departments of the
movie trying to sneak their names in
there is the author of an article or
something there's not a whole lot of
that in misery though and I think it's
because many of the articles are just
copied from real-life local newspapers
and Nye County Nevada where the movie
was filmed it actually shows up a couple
of times if you pay close attention even
though the setting of the movie is
supposed to be clear Creek County in
Colorado the only crew reference Easter
Egg found in too many newspapers that
appear in misery is the article about
Annie being arrested
after the death of several babies in her
maternity ward where it states that her
lawyer is named Steven Pope Elka who is
likely a relative of joseph papp Elka a
production assistant outside of the
newspapers there's also a sticky note in
the police chief's office that says call
Carlson a reference to Charles Carlson
the prop master slashed set dresser and
that's it so let's go back to Annie's
house because it's breakfast time
how was scrambled eggs your specialty I
mean I'm instantly reminded of this one
line in the book where Paul is critical
of her cooking everything she cooked
came out tasting strangely industrial as
if years of eating in hospital
cafeterias had somehow corrupted any
culinary talent she might have once had
not long after she has her first
explosive episode after reading about
miseries death at the end of the final
book she leaves to go away to her
laughing place but before going tells
Paul you better hope nothing happens to
me because if I die you die I feel like
I've heard that somewhere before
thank you mister if he dies you die not
quite but pretty close
Paul sneaks out of the room and nearly
breaks a ceramic penguin which is
actually more of a recurring symbol in
the book where Annie uses it as an
example saying that she knows that
Paul's been out of the room the cops
take a look at it while inspecting the
house in the summer and near the very
end he actually throws it through the
parlor window to get their attention he
also discovers a shrine dedicated to
none other than himself where Annie has
a signed photo in each of the nine
misery books with two copies of the
first days as someone who owns certain
movies on both DVD and blu-ray and
probably will get four K's in the future
I can kind of relate he also snoops
around in the kitchen where if you're
paying attention you may see another
connection to the book in the form of
this calendar that's still stuck on
February because Annie keeps forgetting
to turn the pages in the novel it's in
the guest room that Paul's staying at
where it serves as a byproduct of her
deteriorating mental states but I guess
it's in the kitchen for the film one of
the reasons Paul snuck out of the room
was to get more medication and he has a
plan for what he wants to do
you
[Music]
he empties the capsules into a small
pocket he folds using a piece of
notebook paper and tries to poison Annie
with it at dinner in the scene where
he's emptying out the capsules we see
this strange camera angle and I think
this is a nice point of view there's a
part in the book where she looks into
the room through a keyhole and that's
what I think is going on here and maybe
the reason she knocks over the glass of
wine in the dinner scene is actually no
accident after refilling the glass they
toast to the return of the misery
character and in the days that follow
Paul gets down to work writing the novel
if you look at the pages on the
typewriter many of them are actually
accurate to the text in the book to be
perfectly clear misery by Stephen King
has certain chapters that are just
excerpts from miseries returned by Paul
Sheldon and the text in the typewriter
is often word-for-word there are a
couple of deviations like this part
which corresponds to page 169 but with
an added paragraph to account for the
name change in the movie or Jeffrey is
now known as wind thorn I don't know the
reason for the change though then
there's this shot where the top
paragraph is pulled from page 168 but
the bottom paragraph is new text which
says as the flames crept ever higher
misery realized that only she stood
between something I wonder if this was
added as a foreshadowing of the end of
the movie where misery is actually in
flames literally because paul burns the
book whereas in the novel he hides the
real miseries return and burns a blank
stack of pages to hit anywhere it hurts
most but as Paul progresses with the
book and he realizes that her time with
Paul can't last forever and falls into a
depressive episode that night we see an
exterior of the house during a
thunderstorm the camera is crooked this
is called a Dutch angle and in this case
it's used to signal that Annie is
off-balance mentally you're beautiful
brilliant famous man of the world and
not a movie start time says Kathy Bates
the woman who would win an Oscar for
this role Kathy Bates in misery
I would like to thank Jimmy Caan and
apologize publicly for the ankles
Annie decides to go away again and Paul
sneaks out of the room again where he
finds a nice scrapbook and while these
newspaper articles documenting her
real-life armed as reference heavy as
I'd hoped there is still info we can
pull from that like for example if the
movie feels like it covers a shorter
time span than the book it's because it
does the article claims that Paul's
vehicle was found after one week and
this is not long before the end of the
movie at this point so the whole time
that he was at Annie's in the movie
really only seems to cover a few weeks
maybe a month whereas in the novel he's
in captivity for five months this is one
of the many examples of the movie just
being so much more tame and toned down
one movie change that I did like which
really makes Annie that much scarier as
an antagonist is this detail it says she
was a valedictorian in high school and
graduated nursing school as a Magna cume
lod meaning her grade point average was
almost perfect so in addition to being
this big forceful person she's also very
clever and with two broken legs Paul's
only real hope is to outsmart her in
order to escape his situation as you
know if you watch my channel I love a
good psychological battle and horror
movie another movie differences that we
actually see the police chief trying to
find them rather than just seeing
everything from Paul's perspective and
he even has a little desk cowboy dressed
exactly like him
which I had a little desk cowboy version
of man at some point the Colorado State
Police get involved in searching for
Paul and Buster ends up on the
helicopter to see if he can spot
anything out of the ordinary
now misery is a very Hitchcockian horror
film in particular it's very similar to
Alfred Hitchcock's 1954 film rear window
where the main characters also confined
to a single room after breaking his leg
Hitchcock was known for almost always
making a cameo appearance in his movies
so misery director Rob Reiner decided to
do the same though he is very hard to
identify in his appearance as the
helicopter pilot Hitchcock would not be
the only legendary director that Reiner
took inspiration from there was also a
lot of influence from Stanley Kubrick at
the end of misery we see Paul again
eighteen months later and he's finished
a new novel called the higher education
of Jay Phillips tone God wonder if this
has anything to do with Phillips tone an
actor who often worked with Kubrick and
appeared in Barry Lyndon a Clockwork
Orange and perhaps most notably in The
Shining
the guy who tells jack to call back to
them but I corrected that if that one
seems like a stretch keep in mind that
at the time there were only two Stephen
King novels that took place in his
fictional town of sidewinder Colorado
and those two were misery in the shining
let's move on to the finale
remember how for all those years nobody
know who miseries real father was or if
they'd have be reunited this is an
actual plot point in miseries return the
book within the Stephen King book but it
happens much earlier at the start of
what I assume is basically the second
acts not at the end like how the movie
Paul writes it out eventually Paul
finished her off when he knocks her out
with a pig ornament and this is symbolic
because the pig represents misery and he
has an actual Pig of her own named
misery which Paul doesn't like because
he thought he was done writing the
misery novels so he ends up using misery
against her to finally do away with his
captor there's an interesting scene at
the end where Annie reappears 18 months
later while Paul is at lunch with his
editor but it turns out to just be his
imagination because of the PTSD he
acquired while staying with her this is
meant to be kind of similar to the book
where were given the impression that
Annie survived an ambushed him at his
apartment but it just turned out to be a
writer's scenario it's not really clear
if he imagined it just because of the
PTSD or if he was just letting his mind
wander and write out a worst-case
scenario type of scene that part in the
movie does a good job of recreating that
dynamic because when Paul sees her he
doesn't panic
it just takes him a moment to
concentrate and convince himself that
it's not really Annie because he knows
that she's dead
also the name of the woman who played
the waitress is Wendy Bowers how great
is that it's like Wendy Torrance meets
Henry Bowers and she claims to be his
number one fan as the credits roll we
hear the Liberace song I'll be seeing
you you may remember that Liberace was
Annie's favorite musician Annie Wilkes
is the embodiment of the Toxic fan which
has become an even bigger topic of
discussion in the years since misery's
released so join me in the next episode
of horror history we're all be analyzing
the entire history of Annie Wilkes
remember to subscribe the C's YZ world
for new Horrors every week bring that
death band
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we stay inside
[Music]
you